droht ein Krieg zwischen der Nato und
Russland auf ein solches Szenario müsse
sich das westliche Verteidigungsbündnis
einstellen und zwar in zwei bis 3 Jahren
meint der Militärexperte Fabian Hoffmann
in einem vielbeachteten Post auf X dabei
gehhe es allerdings nicht um einen Krieg
wie Putin ihn gegen die Ukraine führt
sondern um ein anderes Szenario und
darüber wollen wir jetzt mit ihnen
sprechen deswegen grüße ich Herrn
Hoffmann zugeschaltet aus Brüssel hallo
hallo schönen guten Tag her Hofmann ganz
kurz zu ihnen sie sind
Politikwissenschaftler an der Uni Oslo
beschäftigen sich mit strategischen
Waffen und Kapazitäten für militärische
präzisionsschläge und sie haben jetzt
eben auf X so ein ja Kriegsszenario
skizziert was steckt da genau hinter und
wie kommen Sie zu dieser Annahme genau
wir hatten ja jetzt V meht die
Diskussion eine kleine Debatte wie es um
die Wiederaufrüstung der Bundeswehr
steht aber auch gemein der natoallianz
und da wurden ja einige Zeiträume
genannt der Verteidigungsminister selber
hat gemeint und hätte ungefähr 5 bis 7
Jahre nach Kriegsende ich sehe das ein
wenig anders und diese Vermutung die
baue ich sowohl auf die jetzige
fähigkeitslage der Bundeswehr als auch
seiner Alliierten aber auch ganz
explizit wenn man sich eben anschaut was
Russland für Pläne hat bezüglich eines
Krieges
mit der NATO wenn ich mir beide Sachen
anschaue und beide Sachen zusammenrechne
dann komme ich auf einen Zeitraum der
etwas geringer ist ganz wichtig nicht
ein Zeitraum von zwei bis 3 Jahren indem
wir uns mit nachdem wir uns in einem
Krieg mit Russland befinden aber eben
innerhalb von zwei bis 3 Jahren müssen
wir in der Lage sein eine
abschreckungsfähigkeit in Europa mit der
NATO aufzubauen um solche Szenarien
erfolgreich und glaubwürdig abschrecken
zu können mhm jetzt schreiben sie dass
es Russland um einen Wettstreit der
Risikobereitschaft gehen würde dabei
erklären Sie uns kurz was steckt da
genau dahinter und welches Interesse
hätte Russland
daran genau also die Militärstrategie
Russlands baut im Prinzip auf zwei
Komponenten auf das eine sind die
militärischen Fähigkeiten wie es jetzt
auch in der Ukraine zu zu zum Einsatz
kommen und das andere ist eben die
Willenskraft die Willenskraft in einem
Kampf mit der NATO durchzuhalten und
eben auch davon auszugehen dass die NATO
nicht bereit wäre größere immer größer
werdende Risiken in einem Kampf in einer
aktiven Kampfhandlung mit Russland
einzugehen und ihr in diese Richtung
einfach die Willenskraft fehlt um
Russland aktiv und effektiv begegnen zu
können um eben in einem risikowettkampf
wie Russland ihn plant best denen zu
können mhm aber sollte Russland jetzt
tatsächlich die baltischen Staaten
angreifen und dann den nuklearstirm
drüberpannen ist die NATO stark in ihrer
Gegenreaktion eigentlich eingeschränkt
wie könnte ein solcher Schritt Russlands
verhindert werden genau das ist eben die
große Sorge
Russland plant nicht wenn man sich die
russischen Quellen anschaut von
militärischen intellektuellen aber auch
von offiziellen die diese Szenarien in
den letzten ein bis z bei Jahrzehnten
durchaus viel diskutiert und auch
öffentlich diskutiert haben wenn man
sich diese Debatten anschaut wird ganz
klar deutlich Russland plant nicht
unbedingt einen langfristigen Landkrieg
mit der NATO der sich über Jahre hin
weegzieht ähnlich wie wir es jetzt sehen
in der Ukraine ganz im Gegenteil
Russland wusste schon vor dem
ukrainekrieg dass es in einem solchen
Kampf unterleegen sein wird aufgrund der
konventionellen Stärke der der NATO und
aufgrund der Verluste in der Ukraine
weiß es das jetzt erst recht deswegen
hat sich Russland auf andere Szenarien
andere Pläne vorbereitet und eines
dieser Szenarien ist eben dass Russland
versuchen würde sehr schnell ein
wesentlichen Teil des natoterritoriums
einzunehmen z.B im Baltikum wesentlich
heißt hier nicht unbedingt ein ganzes
Land aber zumindest so groß dass es
nicht ignoriert werden könnte von der
natoallianz und im nächsten Schritt
wäre es dann so dass Russland eventuell
sehr schnell seinen nuklearen
Schutzschirm sehr aggressiv über dieses
neubesetzte Territorium ziehen könnte
und mit dem
einhergehend könnte es sogenannte
deeskalationsschläge einsetzen also
präzisions Langstrecken
präzisionsschläge tief in Westeuropa auf
kritische zivile Infrastruktur die
einfach signalisieren den europäischen
Entscheidungsträgern das Widerstand
zwecklos ist dass weiterer Widerstand
nur dazu zu führt das Leid in Europa zu
vergrößern und ebenso die NATO dazu zu
zwingen ähm auf Verhandlungsbasis einen
Frieden mit Russland zu suchen natürlich
ein Frieden der dann den
Sicherheitsinteressen und der
Sicherheitsarchitektur entsprechen würde
wie Russland sie sich vorstellt jetzt
gab's nach ihrem Post auf X auch schon
einzelne kritische Stimmen die dieses
Szenario was sie das geziiert haben so
ein bisschen hinterfragen da ist unter
anderem der Militärhistoriker Janowski
mit dabei der schreibt auf X das sei
Unsinn russland habe nicht die
Fähigkeiten um irgendwas davon zu tun
ein Krieg mit der natoliga außerhalb der
Kontrolle Russlands was entgegnen sie
solchen kritischen Stimmen ich denke
diese Art Analyse und ich glaube das das
trifft den den Punkt meines arguments
sehr deutlich diese Analyse bezieht sich
alleine auf die Fähigkeiten die
militärischen Fähigkeiten Russlands und
da stimme ich den Militärhistoriker
absolut zu und auch anderen Leuten die
auf meinen auf meinen Post eingegangen
sind Russland im Moment was die
militärischen Fähigkeiten angeht ist der
NATO klar unterlegen im konventionellen
Bereich aber die Gefahr es ist eben
gefährlich davon auszugehen dass ob ein
Krieg ob Russland einen Krieg mit der
NATO plant oder nicht hängt alleine vom
konventionellen militärischen
Gleichgewicht in Europa ab das tut es
sicherlich nicht und andere Faktoren
spielen da eine große Rolle und wie
vorhin gesagt die Willenskraft spielt
eine sehr enorme Rolle Rolle darinne
darin ähm wie sehr Russland der Meinung
ist es könnte in einem Kampf mit der
NATO bestehen und ich glaube hier ist
eben die Gefahr dass Russland ein
Szenario erkennen könnte indem es als
Sieger davon geht und es gilt für uns
diese Szenarien aktiv und effektiv
abzuschrecken welche Faktoren spielen in
der konkreten
Rolle ich glaube da da gibt es sowohl
eine militärische als als als auch oder
eine eine physische als auch eine
kognitive Dimension auf der physischen
auf der dinglichen Ebene da geht es ganz
klar um die militärischen Fähigkeiten
ich denke natürlich brauchen wir eine
eine generelle Wiederaufrüstung der
Bundeswehr also eine breit ein breiten
Kapazitätsaufbau
über
mehrere Domänen und und mehrere
Abteilungen ähm allerdings müssen wir
auch in der Lage sein bestimmte
Szenarien so wie ich sie eben skizziert
habe direkt ab zu schrecken vor allem
wenn wir davon ausgehen dass dies die
Szenarien die Strategien sind von
Russland die eventuell präferiert werden
könnten in einem Kriegsfall für das
Szenario dass ich skizziert habe denke
ich ist es enorm wichtig dass wir eine
eine effektive Vorwärtsverteidigung der
NATO aufbauen es muss also absolut klar
sein dass NATO von Tag 1 oder von Stunde
n0 an sind wir bereit und fähig die
natorenze an der Front Linie zu
verteidigen und wir lassen gar nicht
erst zu dass Russland einen wesentlichen
Teil des natoterritoriums einnehmen kann
das müssen wir tun um eben den
psychologischen Druck einer aggressiven
Ausweitung des nuklearen Schutzschirms
Russlands zu entkommen auf der anderen
Seite um um diese sogenannten
deeskalationsschläge zu umgehen also um
effektiv abzuschrecken und verteidigen
ähm Schläge gegen kritische zivile
Infrastruktur in Europa müssen wir
unsere
flugabwehrfähigkeiten weiter und und
noch dramatischer aufbauen als wir es
ohnehin schon tun und ich denke wir
brauchen auch auf jeden Fall eine eine
gegenschlagsfähigkeit wir müssen
Russland signalisieren dass wenn
Russland bereit ist unsere kritische
zivile Infrastruktur anzugreifen wir
zumindest in der Lage sind
zurückzuschießen ich denke diese
Komponente militärische Komponente ist
sehr wichtig allerdings gilt es auch
diese mit einer kognitiven Komponente zu
komplementieren ich glaub glaube was wir
in Deutschland aber auch allgemein in
NATO und V allem in Europa brauchen ist
eine breitere Debatte um diese Kriegs
über diese
Kriegsszenarien was heißt es tatsächlich
mit Russland im Krieg zu stehen nicht
nur wie schrecken wir diesen Krieg ab
sondern auch wie würden wir einen Krieg
führen mit Russland ich denke das ist
enorm wichtig weil wir müssen uns
bewusst sein Russland denkt über diese
Szenarie nach und nicht erst seit
gestern sondern sehr aktiv seit ein bis
zwei Jahrzehnten und was Russland im
Moment sieht ist dass wir absolut nicht
vorbereitet sind über solche und auch
nicht willend sind über solche Szenarien
nachzudenken und ich befürchte das
verstärkt Russlands Gefühl der
Überlegenheit und könnte Russland
weiterhin dazu drängen eventuell
riskante Schritte zu tun mm na ja
Analysen gibt's ja schon ich meine Ende
des letzten Jahres veröffentlichte erst
die Deutsche Gesellschaft für auswärtige
Politik eine eigene Analyse darin heißt
es dass Russland se bis 10 Jahre
brauchen würde um seine Armee soweit
wieder aufzubauen dass es einen Angriff
auf die NATO wagen könnte die Uhr werde
dann äh zu ticken beginnen sobald die
heftigen Kämpfe in der Ukraine zum
Stillstand kämen m wie unterscheidet
sich das jetzt speziell zu ihrem
Szenario also ich kenne die Analyse
natürlich und ich finde die ist sehr gut
gelungen und im Großen und Ganzen stimme
ich diese Analyse auch zu ich denke das
Szenario was ich skizziere stellt
tatsächlich einen absoluten worst case
also ein ein Szenario was passiert denn
tatsächlich im im schlimmsten Fall und
für mich ist eben wichtig die Komponente
der Fähigkeiten also das Element welche
Fähigkeiten haben wir und welche
Fähigkeit brauchen wir auch damit zu
komplementieren direkt auf bestimmte
militärstrategien des potenziellen
Feindes also hier Russlands einzugehen
und dieses sehr gezielt und aktiv
abzuschrecken und ich habe eben die
Sorge äh wie bereits erklärt für
Russland zählen eben nicht nur die
Fähigkeiten sondern auch die
Willenskraft die wir demonstrieren und
wenn wir nicht genug Willenskraft
demonstrieren also nicht signalisieren
dass wir bereit sind auch unter
zunehmendem Risiko den psychologischen
Druck Russland standzuhalten dass wir
uns in aktiven Kampfhandlung in einem
Krieg mit Russland befinden könnten
früher als später und dementsprechend
und das will ich noch mal betonen ich
spreche nicht von zwei bis dre Jahren
bis wir einen Krieg mit Russland haben
aber zwei bis drei Jahre bis wir
zumindest in der Lage sein müssen diese
Worst Case Szenarien abzuschrecken und
ich denke das braucht jetzt ganz
entscheidende und schnelle Handlung